my name is Jeremy Utley I am the
director of executive education at the
Stanford d.school I'm also a lecturer
there so part of my time is spent
working with organizations and helping
them apply the principles and practice
of design thinking in the corporate
setting I also teach classes at the
d.school and right now primarily focused
on equipping student leaders not just to
engage the techniques of design thinking
but really to enable them and equip them
to impart those principles to other
people and to lead teams in a design
thinking manner so I find that my work
with organizations really informs how I
approach students and my work with
students really informs how I then
approach organizational challenges my
background was from finance actually so
I worked in investment management and
found that wanting in some ways and so
switched and work to management
consulting for a while I then shifted
gears and did some work in international
development so worked in Bolivia for a
while starting a startup incubator small
pinch incubator and then worked in
Zambia doing some relief with AIDS
orphans and counseling of children
who've been orphaned by aids and then I
came to business school at Stanford got
my MBA and through the course of my
studies in business school I encountered
the design school over time what I found
is that it's design thinking is no less
rigorous than anything else I've ever
done towards the end of my business
schooling the folks in the design school
asked if I wanted to stick around and
teach and so I've been doing that now
for the last four years
so design thinking at its core is about
understanding and end user of a product
or service could be an external customer
can be an internal constituent
understanding them better than they
understand themselves so that you might
be able to address needs that are latent
that are implicit that they may not even
know about or be aware of with an
innovation that is truly disruptive
truly breakthrough that delights them
that exceeds expectations design
thinking does a really great job of
removing hierarchy from a team and of
removing ego from an idea because it at
the end of the day insights matter your
idea ideas are cheap insights are
expensive and design think he is all
about getting a team to be consistently
able to deliver breakthrough insights
and if you can deliver breakthrough
insights you'll get two ideas that may
be replicable but the ability to develop
and deliver insights routinely is
something that isn't replicable I don't
think
the expertise is increasingly becoming a
liability because the knowledge of what
worked in the past is not predictive
predictive of what's going to work in
the future and so you can't just lean on
your past experience you actually have
to believe that you can bring your full
self to bear in a profoundly new and
fresh way every time you approach a
problem